(audience applauds)
- It's nice to see you in person.
(Alison laughs)
You've been on the show,
I feel like twice, and it's always on Zoom
'cause of COVID.
- It was on Zoom,
so there was always a delay.
I was, you know, it's
just a little tricky.
- [Kelly] It feels outta pocket,
no, but I'm so excited to have you here.
- Yeah, thank you for having me.
- Yes, well it's the holiday season,
but you're planning a
different one right now, right?
- Oh my gosh, I have been planning
my husband's retirement party.
- [Kelly] Oh, that's exciting.
- And he's a California Highway Patrolman,
and so it is a big deal to retire, right?
Like all, every officer
he ever worked with,
who are now, you know, he trained them,
but now they're captains and lieutenants.
And so we're pulling
people outta the woodwork
to come and be a part of this event.
But there's lots of surprises
we've planned for him,
and you know,
a lot of tradition.
- Is he excited about it?
- He is, oh my gosh, he's so excited, yes.
- Yeah, so you're one of the
reigning queens of Hallmark.
- Oh.
(audience claps)
- Everybody-
- You know, the last time I was here,
you told us we were like "The Avengers."
So I'm down-
- It's "The Avengers" of Hallmark.
- I'm down for "The Avengers," yeah.
- "The Avengers" of Hallmark, you three,
you're in all the movies.
(Alison laughs)
I've always seen them,
'cause my sister, my mom,
our whole family, everybody loves them.
- Aww, you're nice.
- So, tell us
about your latest, what's this one?
- Okay, so "Magical
Christmas Village" is so fun
because first of all, it starts with like,
the story of, Marlo Thomas
plays my mom in this movie,
which is amazing.
I know, amazing.
But you know, so there's
the real family dynamic
of her and I having to live together
right before the holidays.
So it's already like a
stressful time of year.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- But she's coming to live with me,
and we are not people
who are meant to be living together.
So-
- It makes a great comedy.
- I know, it's so great.
And she's the queen of
comedy, so that was amazing.
And so that part's really like realistic.
And then, she brings with her
this family Christmas village.
Have you ever seen those
like amazing villages
that people put in their homes?
Do you have one?
(audience laughs)
- I have like a metropolis.
- [Alison] Yeah, yeah.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Oh my God.
- I'm like that crazy lady.
- I love it.
- I have all the Charles Dickens,
like, I have all of it, yep.
- Oh, oh, my, this movie is for you.
Okay, so then-
- Okay.
- But because the little
girl, my character's daughter,
makes a wish when she's putting together
the Christmas village-
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- It maybe has a little magic-
- Ohh.
- Where it's helping,
like she plays with the
figurines, and they-
- I love when magic is involved.
- I do too.
- Yes.
- Especially Christmas magic.
- Life needs it.
- Yeah, yes, so then we
created these characters
for my character, Summer.
She's, you know, she's
got her life together.
She's a single mom.
She's got, you know,
all her ducks in a row.
And so she needed a little magic
to like get her off her game,
to meet up with this guy she
would never have normally met.
- Yeah.
- You know?
So the Christmas village
sort of brings them together.
- And it's Luke, right?
I just had Luke on here.
- Yes, yes, he told me
that he was just here.
- I love him.
He's so nice.
- Such a nice guy.
We had so much fun.
- Yeah, and funny.
- And he's super funny.
- Like his wit, I was like,
"Well that was under the radar."
I was like, yeah.
- He's really, really funny.
But he's also super romantic.
He's so great in this movie.
He's, it was really fun.
- He loves country music.
Of course he's romantic.
- [Alison] Yeah.
(audience laughs)
He was like, "I love
me some Garth Brooks."
I'm like, "I'm sorry, what?"
I was like, "That's awesome."
(audience clapping)
Well, you produced this movie
and you have more in store
with Hallmark, right?
- Yes.
- Did you do like a deal?
I heard a deal, yeah.
- I do have a deal
with Hallmark.
They are so wonderful to work with,
super supportive of-
- Everybody that works with
them says they love their lives.
- Yeah, yeah, because they're
just really supportive
of like telling these female
stories, you know, helping.
I like to bring in a lot of
female directors also, so-
- And they make you feel good.
- And they do, yes.
They're really empowering
and I love working with them, so yes,
I have other projects I'm
working on for next year,
which I'm really excited to come back
and tell you all about.
- Yeah, that's cool,
(audience clapping)
because now you get to
like find stories too-
- Yes.
- That maybe you like,
and you get to produce those, that's cool.
- Yeah, no, I love reading
stories, reading books,
finding IP that I wanna
turn into movies, right?
- Yeah, absolutely.
- You know, it's like,
and I feel like I'm the Hallmark audience.
I'm that person who wants to
watch these romantic comedies.
They're not making them in
feature films anymore, so,
or on the movie screen.
- They really aren't.
- So like, yeah,
come watch Hallmark on a Friday night.
- Yeah.
- [Alison] We're in.
- We love them.
- I love rom-coms.
- I know.
- So this year you celebrated
the, is it your 30th year?
- Yes, oh-
- [Kelly] On "Days of Our Lives?"
(audience cheers)
- I don't do the math a lot.
- That's, like, you
pretty much find people
you like to work with, and you say-
- Yeah, yeah, I'm loyal.
I stick around.
- That's really good though,
that it means also that
it's a great environment.
So that's awesome.
What do you think
about 30 years?
- I feel like I grew up
playing this character,
playing Sami Brady.
I started when I was 16 years old,
and I was-
- Oh my gosh.
- Dopey kid and I just loved it.
I love my job.
I love working there.
The crew, like how all
watched me grow up and-
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Get married and have my own kids.
And then now I get to go
back every once in a while
and visit, and you do get that sense
of just reuniting with everyone again.
- Yeah, that's wonderful.
Well, "A Magical Christmas
Village" premieres tonight
on Hallmark Channel at eight.